Happy Halloween!
It's that time of year when your neighbors
are secretly unwrapping candy,
and brushing lollipops with poison and inserting
razor blades into, pretty much everything.
Actually, while it may be a Halloween tradition
to view your neighbors as psychopaths
who patiently wait for the one trite day of
the year to kill the local kids,
in fact, no child has ever been killed by
a stranger's poisoned candy, ever.
But you know what? facts don't stop fear.
Here are 3 ways in which our misguided terror about Halloween is killing all the fun.
Parents are so scared of letting their kids
roam free that, no joke,
there's now a thing called trunk or treat.
Cars gather in a circle and kids go from one
trunk to the next to grab candy
as if walking around in a circle in a parking
lot and collecting sugar
is the whole point of the holiday.
Yeah, sugar is important,
but so is going outside, with your friends,
on your own, at night.
Some towns are so scared of the holiday that
they've placed curfews on trick-or-treating,
it's medieval, it's as if they really believe
that ghouls come out at night.
There are schools, churches, community centers
sending home notes
begging parents not to let their kids wear
costumes that are too scary.
As if kids can't handle an eyeball oozing
blood any more.
One town even made a guy take down his zombie
decorations in his front yard
because they were, quote: 'too realistic.'
In other words they looked too much like real
zombies?
In some towns, registered sex offenders have
to all gather together at the local precinct
like some twisted version of study hall.
The rules are different in different places,
but they're all based on the idea that sex
offenders pounce on trick-or-treaters,
which, turns out to be, like the poison candy
story, completely false.
There was a study done by a professor now
at Johns Hopkins
and she found that there is zero increase
in child sex offences on Halloween.
In fact, the author Elizabeth Letourneau,
considered titling her study 'Halloween,
the Safest Day of the Year.'
Because it is, when it comes to sex crimes.
There's really just one thing to fear on Halloween and that's cars.
More kids get hit by cars on Halloween than
any other day for obvious reasons.
There are so many more kids outside.
So if we really wanted to make the holiday
safer,
we would take off the cops who were watching
the sex offenders,
and put them on traffic patrol instead.
That could save some lives because cars are
actually dangerous,
unlike a slightly torn Snickers bar.
For Reason TV, I'm Lenore Skenazy.